ce que vous avez le loisir d'assister
avec lui de poing sur la table en actes
et ses six mois le pdg il faut faire ça
faut s'assurer une question dans
l'intérêt des actionnaires dans
l'intérêt des investisseurs
tout ce que ce genre de conversation que
puis à voir avec monsieur lavallée
enfin monsieur lavallée juste pour
peut-être mais dans un contexte c'est
quand même lieu le terme est un peu fort
les yeux avec ti cul et au fond c'est
quelqu'un de très très très faim
il est là depuis le début la création du
fonds à est dit que c'est une personne
qui a aidé à sur le fond que monte le
fond alors c'est son bébé dans quelqu'un
de très puissant qui donc jugé au joug
que j'ai l'impression que je peux
l'inflorescence édition là je comprends
comme étant un ordre
il se positionne comme mon patron que le
dit